now
when something like this happens it just
triggers that nerve and it just raises
the interest all over again
the body found in lake mead has many
thinking about our city's history with
organized crime a lot of people asking
questions especially those who write
about las vegas is solved in unsolved
cases good afternoon thanks for joining
us at four i'm kirsten joyce and i'm
christian casadas joe muller spoke to
two crime water writers about the barrel
mystery and he reports this afternoon
from lake mead
that barrel found here at lake mead is
leaving a lot of people curious about
who the victim is and curious about if
there are more barrels out here to be
found i dive i haven't seen any bodies
under the water i've seen some boats
sunken boats lots of fish but uh if i
came across something like that it'd
probably scare the heck out of me
boulder city resident todd reams says it
is the talk of the town the now homicide
investigation is capturing the attention
of crime riders too at this period in
time it's kind of a waiting game i think
anthony smith and megan madden created
mayhem in the desert they write about
las vegas past murders and crime
including many mob-related killings this
case is catching their attention now
they can't help but wonder what will
unfold next and what kind of story this
could lead to once they start finding
things in lake mead that maybe a lot of
crimes will be connected possibly solved
because i mean right now we really have
no idea what's out there i mean we all
can guess a little bit about what we
think is out there people we talk to out
here at lake mead say they'll be paying
a little bit closer attention to the
items they come across in the lake and
around it reporting at lake mead joe
mohler live local now